look if I'm gonna talk about a Harry
Potter mouth fly my house colors okay so
there is a bit of news ish thing that
dropped a couple of days ago in regards
to the follow-up film - fantastic beasts
and where to find them still currently
titled fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald god that is a lousy title to
have to work my way through but
apparently there is a little bit going
on a little bit of a controversy to some
degree in regards to a specific
character or more specifically in
regards to something that will not be
depicted about that character and it has
resulted in a certain stripe of the fan
base that is upset by that and it has
also resulted in a stripe of fandom that
is confused bewildered or angered by the
fact that there is a side that is upset
by this
so before I dive into this little bit
about my own credentials I have read
every single one of the Harry Potter
books I have read the cursed child I
owned all eight of the movies I have
seen fantastic beasts I don't own it I
didn't like it enough to buy it
and this this I am actually a Slytherin
I was officially sorted in in Pottermore
and my Patronus is a squirrel for the
record so that's my base level
credentials I am a Harry Potter fan I'm
not like a mega fan but I enjoy this
world these stories I enjoy them a lot
and I have for a while so what happened
was it was basically confirmed by both
David Yates the director of the film and
by JK Rowling who of course is the
originator of everything Harry Potter
that the details of the past
relationship between the characters of
Dumbledore and Grindelwald being
portrayed in this particular film by
Jude Law and Johnny Depp is not gonna be
gone into in specific explicit depth to
put it another way the fact that
Dumbledore is gay and had a romantic
pull towards Grindelwald when they were
both young men is not going
to be brought up now if you if the fact
if what I've just said you're like what
what are you talking about so here's the
thing this was never something that was
ever made explicit in the books or any
of their of the official media to date
so far however after the seventh book
was released
JK Rowling came forward and said that
Dumbledore is gay and in his past he had
a very close relationship with
Grindelwald now that much we do know
that is mentioned in the books like once
maybe twice but the details of that
relationship are not made explicit in
the books and what she said outside of
that is that Dumbledore is gay he had a
strong romantic attraction to
Grindelwald Grindelwald did not
reciprocate it but used but recognize
that you used it to manipulate and take
advantage of Dumbledore for a time we
don't have full details on that because
as I said we only have the snippets that
she has said now that as much as it is
very least it is being presented as the
intent of the writer and theoretically
informed the way she's written these
characters that is not going to be made
explicit in the new film which is odd
considering that it features both of the
characters that are key to this
relationship that is not going to be
depicted now the result of this is that
there is a fair chunk of fans who are
somewhere in the LGBTQ range who
basically are upset that it's not going
to peer in the film and then there are
people who look at that reaction and
either don't see what the big deal is or
are for some reason angry that other
people are upset and that part am I
really gonna deal with because that's
just bizarre to me but I do feel like it
is worth adjusting for people who think
who see that reaction don't think it's a
big deal so let me start by trying to
explain why and then I'll sort of
address the other side of it as well
because I want to try and be I want to
try and you know be fair to the
piratey of what it is that's going on so
the thing that is upsetting for any fan
who falls anywhere into the LGBTQ
spectrum and a quick reminder if you're
new to the channel and didn't already
know this I land in there what's
frustrating is that there is present no
definitive representation of LGBTQ in
the Harry Potter world not in the text
itself not in the books not in the
movies now there are any number of
reasons why that could have not been the
case but it was a little bit of a coup
for those kinds of fans to be told by
Rowling granted after the books were
done that the this additional fact about
Dumbledore it it gave them someone to
connect with and that's not to say like
you can't relate to a character that
doesn't share your sexuality or your
gender identity or whatever because
that's ridiculous oh well we're in
character you can always connect to it
but it felt meaningful that there was
not only some representation but that it
was one of the key characters it was one
of the most powerful Wizards in this
world that felt important there are some
people who were even at the time a
little bit annoyed you know why didn't
you put it in the books in the first
place and I'll address that quickly
because I think that feeds into some of
the reaction to the reaction and the
thing about that is and the reason it
never bothered me is that the details of
Dumbledore's past his history really any
of it his romantic inclinations and
pretty much anything else doesn't need
to be there
we actually get very few specific
details about really any of the adult
characters unless a specific detail that
they give us pertains to the immediate
story that's going on because it's about
the students it's not about their
teachers and JK Rowling is a better
writer
to just have a character sit down and
spout their history at us unless it has
an immediate bearing on what's going on
right now
and because the books are written pretty
explicitly from Harry's perspective I
mean it's not so it's not a first-person
perspective strictly speaking but it
never leaves Harry's point of view
except for the opening prologue segment
at the beginning of each book other than
that we are completely restricted to
Harry's view and he's the only character
who's thought-process we get to see so
for all intensive purposes is
practically a first-person perspective
so coming out this from Harry's
perspective he's not gonna know these
things about these people these adults
his his mentors his teachers even the
ones he really likes and there isn't a
reason for them to tell him a lot of
this stuff so there just wasn't an
occasion where that particular aspect of
Dumbledore's past really would have been
relevant to what was going on there
wasn't a reason for him to talk about it
and frankly I was kind of okay with it
on that basis I don't think that
argument holds quite as much water with
what we're dealing with with the
upcoming film though now granted I have
to stick a big asterisks on this for the
fact that I haven't seen the film you
haven't seen the film we haven't read
the scripts so you know allow me some
wiggle room that depending on the end
result of the film itself it could alter
some of these things but the film is
going to feature both Grindelwald and
Dumbledore in the same film supposedly
one would assume on opposite sides of a
conflict there is not only an
opportunity but a reason to have their
past which would include confirming
Dumbledore's homosexual inclinations to
be it's it's relevant I mean it matters
it's hard to imagine why it wouldn't
matter in this case because I think
honestly well it's a neat detail about
the character if that information didn't
matter and Harry Potter it it honestly
didn't I would have liked if it had been
there but it didn't matter it's a lot
harder to argue that it doesn't matter
in this movie
coming up because their their past how
can their past with each other not
matter so either you don't bring it up
at all in any way in which you like
their past at all not just the gay
aspect but the fact that they have
history together at all in which case
why is Dumbledore even there if you're
not going to acknowledge their past
together but if he's there you do
acknowledge their past together but you
fail to acknowledge that specific aspect
that happens to confirm Dumbledore
standing as a member of the LGBTQ
community
well you've kind of made it conspicuous
by its absence like well you have the
perfect opportunity to weave this in
naturally it it's relevant there is a
reason to talk about it
and you're not going to that seems weird
to some people that seems disingenuous
and just in case anyone's thinking well
it's a movie for kids there shouldn't be
homosexual stuff in it I'm just gonna
say two things about that real quickly
firstly the movies probably gonna be
pg-13 because fantastic beasts was so
while I have no doubt it'll appeal to
children it's not being made explicitly
for that target audience and besides
that I don't buy the argument that you
have to shield children from the LGBTQ
community than the fact that they just
exist especially in a series that
already has plenty of heterosexual
affection left right and center
including two characters appearing to
make out naked in one of the last films
in the main series so no but there are
so people who are you know yeah I I
think pot you know beyond just the
people who find LGBTQ people and
acknowledgement that they exist
inherently offensive and if that's the
case for you then I assume you've
already checked out of this video and
you aren't even watching at this point
or you're still watching in order to
slag me off in the comments in which
case I honestly I have nothing to say to
you and it's not because I'm trying to
be a jerk is because if that's what you
believe there's nothing I can say that
this kind of change that but I do
believe that there are people who that
is not the case for them who are still
confused or frustrated by the the
adverse reaction that is coming from
some fans and like I said in many to in
many ways this is about representation
and theoretically right now Dumbledore
is the representation for any and
everybody who is not heteronormative so
that's that's a fair chunk of people who
right now have been told that he
represents them but have yet to be shown
that he represents them and I think
where some people feel to a certain
degree almost insulted is right now JK
Rowling is that risk of basically
looking like the entire reveal of
Dumbledore being gay wasn't ever genuine
in the first place and it is starting I
don't know I don't know if I believe
this or not but I can see how and I
myself can make the argument that it's
starting to look like she waited until
the books were done never put it
explicitly in the text said that he was
gay which was throwing a bone to LGBTQ
fans and then when the tank when the
time came that not only an opportunity
presents itself but this it actually
makes total logical sense as a story for
that finally to be canonized in the
official media that it's not being done
she's not putting her money where her
mouth is and it makes the entire
announcement of Dumbledore being gay
start to look like very cynical tokenism
like the only reason she said it was to
make a certain kind of fan happy but
she's not prepared to back it up in any
way substantively in the text in a way
that can't be denied
cuz that that's the thing and I had and
cuz I suspect there also some people
like well if you know he's gay why does
it have to be said in the movie why
isn't it enough just to know that
because acknowledgement is important and
it'll end something like Harry Potter
acknowledgement in
the text is important part of what's got
me thinking about this also is I'm
working on a video for later on down the
line where I'm gonna be talking about
authorial intent and how much the intent
of an author does or doesn't matter in
terms of the assessment of the work and
like I said I'm still working on that
but in regards to how it applies here
JK Rowling can say all day long that she
always intended wo to be gay that she
wrote him with the idea that he was gay
and had this attraction to a man who
betrayed him as being influential in the
way she wrote the character she can
claim that all she wants but there's
nothing concrete in the text that states
it which means that okay yes LGBTQ fans
or any other people who wish who desire
to believe what she's saying they can
accept that but anyone who doesn't like
it also doesn't have to and that makes
it not truly an intrinsic unremovable
part of the character not if it's not in
the text the underlying idea of it's
fine if a character's like this we don't
want to hear about it that speaks to a
very painful truth to a very high
percentage of the LGBTQ population which
is we don't want to have to think about
you and that's a long-running problem
that every part of this population has
had to deal with whether they are
closeted or people simply just don't
want to acknowledge them even if they
are out the whole notion of you know be
whatever you want to be but I don't want
to have to see it you know very much
lines up with fine Dumbledore's gay why
does it have to be said because until
it's said it can be denied it can be
ignored like many members of the LGBTQ
community have or do feel that they are
ignored you know I'll make a comparison
and so slightly we are one and maybe it
doesn't work but I'm gonna try anyway
imagine if when Captain America Civil
War came out black panther showed up and
he never took that helmet off never took
the mask off we never saw that he was a
black man he's just there he's always in
the suit and he's still a hero he still
he does all the stuff but we never see
him we never see confirm visually that
he is in fact a black man and I'm sure
there will be some people would say well
what's it matter
I mean you know he's black under that
why do you have to see it because
representation doesn't have weight if
you don't actually see it and in a case
like that if Marvel had pulled something
like that there would have been all
kinds of people calling BS on that would
have been going what why can't you just
show it it becomes weirder that you
aren't acknowledging it if it is
supposedly a major aspect of this
character it's weirder the longer you go
without acknowledging then just to get
five seconds five seconds have black
panther take the helmet off oh look he
is black and another thing that I won't
think is worth pointing out on this is
at this point I believe it's pretty
clear that Harry Potter is prevalent
enough as a franchise it is going to
outlive Rowling it is going to continue
on past her lifespan the way that Mickey
Mouse lived past is neither way the
Sherlock Holmes live pass Arthur Conan
Doyle Harry Potter is still going to be
around and it will be continued by other
people and if she doesn't put somewhere
concretely confirmed undeniably that
Dumbledore or anybody is a member of the
LGBTQ community than any other creator
that picks up the pen after her is under
absolutely no obligation to continue
that because it was a background element
it was never explicitly said because the
canon is the text the canon is not what
was in the writers head the canon is
what you can find concrete
evidence for in the body of the work
itself everything else is interpretable
so if it's not there no one else's will
be under any obligation to put it there
and right now we are talking about the
tenth film in a series and for all the
films and all the characters and there's
a lot of characters there has yet to be
a single concrete definitive
representation within the books of an
LGBTQ person as of right now when it
comes to the text of this work we don't
exist now if I'm gonna backpedal from
this a little bit and give a little bit
of benefit of the doubt or possibly
silver lining I am loathe to make the
argument maybe they'll address it next
movie cuz I hate that like I really hate
that I I get really like to my core
infuriated when people try and tell me
that some things that I see as wrong in
a film is okay because maybe the next
one will fix it I don't care if it does
it's still a problem in this movie but
I'm still gonna kind of make that claim
at least as being potential and here's
why so I said that it is bizarre that
this film is going to be having both
Dumbledore and Brenda Wald
and not address the specifics of their
past relationship it is possible because
unlike a lot of other franchises like
say the dark universe or you know
whatever non-starters or things that
fall apart this isn't a case of we're
putting out this movie and we have plans
for later ones but we have to see how
this next one does like they're actively
planning the next three of these already
and I guarantee you that they make at
least one more after this even if this
one under performs so there will
absolutely be at least one more of these
movies and if they are planning out
properly for
full yeah I believe they said it was
five it was five or six movies however
long it's gonna be then it is possible
that even though Dumbledore Angra dwell
both appear in this movie maybe they
don't share a scene together maybe even
though they're both here it doesn't
actually happen yet that there is a that
the circumstances happened that would
require Dumbledore to acknowledge this
past because maybe it's something he's
ashamed of again not because he's gay
but because he fell in love with someone
horrible and maybe he's loathe to admit
that maybe he doesn't want to have to
think about that and perhaps the
circumstances that would force him to
properly confront that and own up to it
don't happen in this movie maybe they
happen in the next movie having said
that even if that is the case it's still
not great because at this point because
of the reaction that has happened and
watching David Yates and JK Rowling try
and cover up and explain and justify
even if it was always the plan to get
into this in more detail in the next
movie after crimes of Grindelwald it
doesn't matter because now because of
what's happened
it looks reactionary so even if it was
always the plan from the get-go what it
looks like is they didn't address it
people got ticked off then they put it
in it looks again like tokenism it looks
like you're only doing it to placate a
fanbase and unfortunately that's another
thing that's actually gonna rile up the
people who get annoyed by that because
they're gonna go oh you only did it
because these people complained about it
political correctness gone mad and it's
just the whole handling of it Stokes the
fire
who's Stokes the fight Stokes the
argument and this is the fight that
should not be happening and again my
frustration is and until I see the movie
and if it turns out that the opportunity
genuinely isn't there okay but I do
honestly believe there's probably ample
opportunity to just get this information
in there and if she was serious when she
said the first time
made the announcement that Dumbledore is
gay if she meant it and it wasn't
tokenism and it wasn't a meaningless
bone with no meat on it being heard -
being thrown out to a certain stripe of
fans that she wanted to appeal to then
it would have been a much better idea to
put it in the second film and just have
it there because then you could say we
were always planning to do this because
here it is and there wouldn't have been
a heck of a lot of things to base an
argument of you only did this because
people complained and now honestly no
matter what its gonna look like that if
it's a dress in a later movie even worse
than that is if we get more movies and
it still never gives addressed because
if they have opportunity after
opportunity after opportunity and they
still don't make it clear and I'm not
saying like I need to see Jude Law
kiss Johnny Depp I actually don't want
to see that but just something some
piece of dialogue some just pause like
just Dumbledore saying I was very close
to him once and just somebody in the
room saying close in what way and just a
pause and a look of sorrow and he turns
away just something something that says
it was more than a friendship for him
because if we get multiple films and we
don't even get that nothing then that
will have revealed Rowling and anyone
else within the Harry Potter creation
team that was pushing the idea that
Dumbledore was an olive branch to LGBTQ
communities it will have revealed them
as cynical manipulators who don't
actually care and weren't prepared to
back it up out of some fear that it
would get labeled propaganda aimed at
kids and as can it becomes kowtow into
this idea that simply being anything
other than straight and cisgender is
somehow inherently offensive and that's
wrong but we're also not there yet
where we are right now is a regrettable
place for lots of fans I think on both
sides of this debate this is a place I
don't
we should be in but we're here now it's
not as bad as it could be it's not as
bad as some fans I think are making it
out to be but it's also not nothing and
like I said I'm prepared to extend a
very limited sliver a benefit of the
doubt for this next film which is a film
I don't think is gonna be very good
anyway so I mean that's a separate
conversation but if we get another film
after this and they still can't take
five seconds one shot to give us
something then it becomes something that
they are avoiding it becomes something
that it becomes clear that they wished
they hadn't said about this character
and that they won't acknowledge and that
is now actually taking away something
that was given to a community here here
is a representation here's a character
that is like you but if you don't
acknowledge it in the film
after repeated opportunities to do so
appropriately then you've effectively
you've just taken that away and I hope
that doesn't happen I hope that's not
the case
also the movies good even though I think
it won't be so lots of things I hope for
this movie but we'll see so those are
sort of my thoughts trying to explain
give my feelings about this whole thing
I think that's gonna wrap it up I have
an increasing amount of faith in the
subscriber base that I've been
cultivating so even though I know I've
just talked about a fairly contentious
subject I'm hoping and I'm hopeful that
even people who disagree with me we can
keep it civil and no personal attacks
and with that outlined whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
compliments let's talk about it you know
if you like what I do you want to
support me you can do so through patreon
and also there's all the things you know
the things likes and subscribes and
listen to my podcast and follow me on
Twitter links for all that stuff's down
below so until next time expelliarmus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]